I'm gonna Newt my way down the Deuter
hole hello everybody my name is
markiplier welcome back to been in head
I really like this game so I'm gonna
play a lot more of it I and I'm probably
gonna be a lot better at it because I'm
not gonna dicker what is Oh stupid
backstage again are we about to get in
the story of Ben and Ed are you gonna
tell me why ed has been taken from I'm
Ben sorry I get us confused sometimes
because we're very similar oh whoa Hodge
okay ah whoa oh oh my god that is
terrifying
can I close the door again can i lock
myself in this room I mean I just want
to stare at these paintings of the
lovely show master over and over for
ages and ages because he's my master and
I love him so much and I adore him and I
die endlessly paru over and over and
over and over
Oh sounds great dad Wow
what oh I broke the game Oh lovely it's
like portal is like being stuck in the
portal I have no idea what that was but
this is like being stuck in the portal
levels because when you go outside of
the factor or outside of the testing
facility you could see a lot of other
elements of it I broke the game I'm back
in my streak constantly breaking every
game I play oh it is so cool oh I broke
it so badly
oh why yeah I'm back together where'd
those robot arms come from I have no
idea Hagen's boss oh [ __ ]
okay bad
dude oh that's cool okay that's enough
for me haha
okay enough breaking the game time to
get actually back into it oh my lord and
say ooh well that's less appealing than
my Lord and Savior the show master ha oh
okay that's really disturbing why is
there a plate full of eyeballs here I
mean I know it's a zombie apocalypse and
everything but goddamn that's horrifying
cut off legs crawl that seems
counterintuitive to everything that I
would like to do in my world Oh laughs
at the week my favorite pastime and this
is lovely oh why does this exist here
god this game reminds me of something I
mean it's kind of got Octodad elements
to it oh god why
okay wahahahaha that is not the girl
that I was expecting but I guess for
proper weight distribution that makes
sense
half only I can figure out what the hell
the shadows that we're moving in the
wall were ha I'm a maniac I'm a maniac
wow they did a lot of animation for this
one it's really cool really well done I
got it man really well done
Oh up up up up up no no okay off we go
then to the actual game what why not
well it is creepy Oh lovely oh look at
that okay is that where I'm going next I
still don't know where the secret things
are hey hello hi aim throw and come back
to the body
boink yay well part of my body anyway oh
I'm supposed to go up there okay so let
me just make sure that I've got
everything over here who betrays his
best friend for a mediocre price oh
that's an actual show by the mastermind
behind this one okay I got the tour fine
I guess we're okay oh there oh that's
what it was I'd almost made it to the
end Holly it you who against your Ben
I'm coming for you baby
Oh Ben you got really quiet it's really
creepy show master - I love you oh man
this is dream come true kind of hello ah
[ __ ]
well if I'd better god this is the dog
oh that's the one that I was supposed to
fall down infinitely and do okay
whoopsies I didn't mean to break game
guys just happens oh no not the cloud
not the horrifyingly haunted clown
that's what it was this reminded me of
bewilder house everybody loves clowns
well if I could make a counterpoint to
that argument because I for one think
that's the creepiest [ __ ] I've ever seen
in my entire life I mean hot damn that
is oh it's a boss how am I gonna do that
oh my god but it's terrifying oh god I
gotta shoot myself at it through cannons
this is some horrifying horrifying
nightmare dream night Mandarin yeah
that's all
okay let's see how I can kick your ass
giving your big and special
oh no I'm big and stomping I know how to
get secret out of you her shortcut ELISA
come on try to get me [ __ ] you didn't
you slap me slap the [ __ ] out of nobody
ah what the hell was on his head there
we go thank you
oh god damn it get on here come back
here you [ __ ]
Oh ma'am I can do this I know I can
super secret a [ __ ]
I got smashed a bit okay in over there
let's do this right
thank yes might as well since this guy's
being a giant dude candy sausage that
doesn't look like sausage Alex
horrifying yeah
boy those laughs sure are reassuring
[ __ ] Gandhi
what I'm not dead I'm not dead I'm still
alive
all right miss man dig miss me ass bag
ah huh pass on you god damn I had it
twice son of a [ __ ] son of a badge all
right now we got this now I got it don't
worry everybody my skills what [ __ ] was
that
ah but [ __ ] you
Erica oh god what's that
how now crippled Cindy oh lordy Lou play
with me forever
I don't wanna guys are hung that's not
fun at all
Oh what is happening down hello okay
then what why Oh Canon okay I should
hurry up my hand isn't coming up huh
Frick die let go of me
some men ah [ __ ] sometimes I think when
the thumbs go earth-1 that when he's
bumping his hands like I think like it
causes him to jump and that caused
problems
Oh
[ __ ] I'm okay it's okay I'm not mad I'm
not angry I'm not angry of why why why
the physics are a little wonky in this
game you know I'm just gonna I didn't
want to point it out but chess Elwha
just a wee bit wonky you know ah miss me
and where am I suppose it ah oh ah [ __ ]
god damn it ah man this taken for a
while
I thought I was supposed to hit him
maybe in his head or get in the mouth
that's usually where I try to get it in
no one take that out of context please I
mean this is actually you know this high
functioning for this uh
yeah I don't know what the point of that
is but I did it now huh don't roll off
you [ __ ]
thank you
okay let me see if there's something
like in the back of his head cough that
is terrifying
yeah ha ha ha Oh suck it [ __ ] hey you
don't look so good
hello was he waving at me I mean I did
kind of just shred some of his brain so
it's understandable
oh no he's faster now wolf mine goodness
alright so now I'm imagining that cannon
it's gonna be out of commission because
the clown got angry because the clown
somehow has grow geez ohms alrighty then
no God [ __ ] me God
ah [ __ ] up here we go I think the thumps
definitely do knock me up and it just so
happens to coincide with some weird like
physics stuff it's gonna knock me
sky-high
ha ha
this is where going slower is kind of
important ow whoa ah [ __ ] I don't know
if that's important
Oh
okay come at me [ __ ] yeah Nick Nick
Nick hey Manny ah thank you [ __ ]
boink okay Lennon
got it
I'm coming for you [ __ ] Oh keep
laughing mother humble huh bike yeah
caught in your gearbox you know in these
old I mean I'm a very fragile system I
don't know why I'm hurting it so badly
with just my spindly body well that's
not fun that's that's the opposite of
fun huh let's carry me okay we're fine
we're okay
somehow damaging his gear make [ __ ] was
that oh my god you've got off [ __ ] you
hi i'm kurt wheeling into this okay
we're okay now just don't [ __ ] slap me
like that it was very intrusive which
waiting okay I can deal with that I
think why not
hey whoa cheese that's a little faster
than I'd like
that's a little faster new noon mother
hover laughs okay okay I'm gonna Newt my
way down the Deuter hole that sounded
weird but it's what's gonna happen can
you just can you just
all right whatever yeah okay yeah okay
we're okay we're okay ah for cheese or
cheese yeah okay oh cheese cow quad
cheese I think I'm safe over here yep
just barely whoo boy whoo here we go oh
jeez that was close okay one more oh
[ __ ] me ha I thought that was my balls
huh get in there get in there
thank you okay lead the target I don't
get bad at all
feel like a champion I feel like the
biggest winner in the world oh it's
probably something that I missed I'm
gonna explore it while I can
was that over there Jess um hey is
anybody something here your secrets
I'm gonna jump on the top here for you
Ned and I'm not poor all the fingers out
of your brains
I'm a zombie and zombie brain and you
are one do for you oh stop being so
dizzy [ __ ] I'm coming for your blue
lashus brains nothing gonna stop the
zombie head yeah yeah I am sorry all
right which way where are they ah [ __ ]
where are they are those ding-dang cans
where are those ding-dong or cans Oh
Gersh weirdos ding-dong cans at Al Hill
well that is it's quite ineffective
there we go
I needed to put my full body weight
behind that one I don't see no cans I
don't see nothing
he's just been in like an idiot
nothing up there huh oh god oh gosh
alright then baby behind me oh there's
cans back here who would have known who
would even is affected posh husky okay
those are the last two cans that I
needed Hey
persistence and stupidity and my own
arrogance have won the day I will never
be at a lot things dangerous well I
think he's just bowing down to worship
me
thank you clown for the respect that I
obviously deserve hello Ben ignore the
fact that I almost left bye
oh he's gone okay there we go okay so
that is been an egg I don't know how
many more episodes I'm gonna play I
don't hey I'm gonna do a full
playthrough this but there's a lot of
fun like these levels very well that is
terrifying
whoa that is even worse so these levels
are very creative and interesting and I
don't know how many there are
there are 23 bonus level unlocked ooh
is that good bonus oh god I want the
bonus all right but I'll save that for
another let me know what you think down
the comments below and let me know if
you want see more better net there's a
lot of fun so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye I am the
precursor to being that terrifying
little girl in the woods
I am the nightmare tonight
I'm about to get to do what you do not